vous nous direz laquelle des deux
informations ensuite a retenu votre
attention et on va commencer Véronique
par une pépite pépite yvelinoise issue
du territoire de Paris Saclay qui a
lancé une ligne de lunettes 100%
française et éco-responsable et
fabriquer ici en Île de France ça
s'appelle une Horia le nom de la c'est
la marque de lunettes c'est Joël Nguyen
en fait qui est designer d'objets
opticien et après il était il est devenu
ingénieur aussi il a voulu c'est un
objet qui lui plaisait il a voulu créer
de belles lunettes mais d'une façon un
peu différente parce que la production
de masse maintenant elle est elle est
complètement partie en Asie parce que ça
revient trop cher et après lui ce qu'il
voulait c'était éco-responsable fabriqué
sur place sur mesure et ne pas trop
produire en fait donc il faut qu'il
travaille avec des opticiens un peu
différents pas des opticiens qui ont qui
qui ont qui appartiennent à une chaîne
mais des opticiens ah là il me faisait
l'analogie avec un caviste un caviste
indépendant qui va aller chercher des
bouteilles que personne ne connaît et un
caviste de chaîne qui va avoir à tout le
monde aura la même chose mais lui ce
sont ces opticiens là avec qui il a
envie de travailler et alors pourquoi
c'est un objet correspondable donc c'est
fait sur place et c'est aussi durable
parce que comme ils disent qu'on sait
fabriquer ou c'est le réparer donc c'est
lunettes elles peuvent vous durer tout
votre vie il voulait pas rond jusqu'au
bout voilà après donc c'est du
sur-mesure je voulais déjà dit vous avez
plein de modèles alors là il y a
gentiment apporté tout un tas de modèles
alors ça c'est le le best of le Must
voilà les lunettes de soleil après il y
a plein de couleurs
à ce niveau là comme ça on les voit
voilà on les voit à la caméra du verre
voilà lui il est asiatique allez me
racontait que souvent il y avait des
problèmes au niveau du nez parce qu'il
est le nez est différent enfin bref donc
c'est vraiment ça qu'il a aussi
sensibilisé donc au sur-mesure voilà et
puis qu'est-ce que je pourrais vous dire
d'autre
voilà voilà
l'opticien du coup n'a pas de stock
superflu puisque il y a quelques
montures et après les gens disent bon
moi je l'avais en rouge en bleu voilà
parce qu'en fait il faut savoir que les
opticiens lambda ils ont tous les ans
enfin chaque changement de collection et
80 % de leur stock qui est juste jeté
ils ont les tiroirs plein plein de
montures qui ne collection changent et
ben voilà donc c'est quand même pas très
écolo ça et donc lui ça ça évite
justement ce gâchis et
puis voilà et puis il a une autre vie
aussi il est coach en entrepreneuriat en
fait tous ces jeunes c'est pépites qui
sont sur le plateau de Saclay qui sont
dans des écoles prestigieuses il les
aide en fait ils rendent un peu ce qu'il
a vécu lui c'est à dire que il les aide
à monter leur entreprise avec une
optique toujours éco-responsable enfin
etc et aller au bout de leur de leur
sujet de leur démarche et lui en fait
cette boîte il l'a monté avec un associé
donc une Orient et ça fait deux ans
qu'ils existent et s'ils ont mis presque
un an et demi à quand même mettre au
point la chaîne de fabrication parce que
c'est quand même
très très particulier parle d'une usine
4.0 il faut que ça soit flexible agile
enfin j'y connais rien mais ça m'allait
drôlement pointu et drôlement
intelligent et ingénieuse qu'ils ont ce
qu'ils ont créé voilà et puis alors
l'histoire d'une mère et de sa fille qui
viennent de créer un vêtement qui peut
s'avérer
utile cet été sur la plage et pas que
sur la page voilà exactement en fait
c'est l'histoire de casting donc qui est
styliste qui était styliste dans une
autre vie et de sa fille Mao qui est
prof de yoga et coach sportif qui un
jour casting offre à Mao un long gilet
en tissu fluide indien et Mao et emballé
parce que parce que c'est léger parce
que ça tourne ça flotte ça couvre enfin
bref et elles ont l'idée de de tenter de
créer un vêtement dans cet esprit là
alors elles ont choisi comme tissu la
gaz de coton la gaz de coton c'est une
trame très très aéré donc c'est un tissu
très léger très agréable pour l'été et
qui laisse passer l'air etc qui est très
agréable et très doux à même la peau
voilà alors après il a fallu trouver un
nom donc c'était un peu entre le kimono
et la cape et puis il y a le yoga aussi
qui est important dans la vie de Mao
donc elles sont arrivées à trouver kimio
voilà qui résume un peu tout ça et elles
ont créé par un soir de pleine lune un
patron elles ont designé le le vêtement
qui est et ça fait penser un peu à une
cape et et c'est un côté protecteur en
fait aussi parce que vous pouvez vous
cacher dedans quand vous prenez le métro
ou que vous allez dans les transports en
commun et que vous êtes en mini-jupe
vous allez au sport en legging bien
moulant vous êtes peut-être un peu
contente d'avoir un truc qui vous cache
et ça c'est un mouvement ou une
expression aussi qui vient des
États-Unis le subwayshirt tel que les
filles maintenant elles se mettent un
gros t-shirt moche pour cacher leurs
vêtements trop courts et qui pourrait
leur
comment dire elle pourrait se faire
agresser ou avoir des mots des remarques
voilà des obligeante etc donc toi ce ce
qui Myo qui qui peut flotter derrière
vous pouvez être fier et le porter
fièrement si vous vous sentez vous avez
envie d'être vu et moi j'en ai un alors
je peux vous montrer le logo et ou alors
vous avez envie d'être dans un cocon et
si vous avez envie d'être dans un cocon
il vous protège et puis vous protéger du
soleil aussi sur la plage et vous êtes
accompagné par tout et alors dernière
petite chose donc c'est fait ici c'est
elle qu'ils font à la main c'est donc
vraiment circuit court à la commande il
y a leur Instagram et elle cherche un
ESAT pour la broderie justement de
l'étiquette voilà
le service c'est d'être par le travail
ou peuvent travailler des personnes en
situation d'handicap voilà elles
aimeraient beaucoup trouver ça bon ça se
trouve pas comme ça en 5 minutes on
avait trouvé un mec qui était déjà bien
bouquet donc voilà elle appelle à qui
qui sait qui connaît qui veut ça donnera
un côté encore plus généreux à ce projet
donc la télé passée ici bravo à ces deux
initiatives français laquelle a retenu
votre attention Francis
bien de se renseigner auprès de ces deux
heures
après faut qu'ils aient encore
voilà
la combinaison c'est bien lunettes et
combinaison voilà c'est très bien je
connais Paris
ouais tout pour pour l'été merci
Véronique c'était la dernière chronique
des insolites avant la fin de cette
saison qui se termine à la fin de la
semaine pour pour le 7 8 vous partez en
vacances un petit peu de un petit peu de
repos de campagne écouter le silence
c'est les petits oiseaux
pour le 7 8 la saison prochaine version
en tout cas bonnes vacances à vous merci
bonne vacances à